[Applaudissements]
tu allais faire doucement benhaim là là
les téléspectateurs vont aimer benhaim
vous allez nous faire sans langue de
bois
c'est cette fois dans la rue mais je me
dis rien c'est de la langue de bois avec
une bouazzi alors sans langue de bois
vous avez travaillé avec stéphane bern
j'adore avec arthur mallory c'est tout
avec arthur stéphane bern 2 savane
oui moi oui foucault vous allez faire
votre top 5 du moins celui que vous
aimez le mois salut vous aimez le plus
sain et attention et vous pouvez me
mettre dernier je vous le dis mais l'aïe
ne soyez pas hypocrites dire l'amérique
du nord mais non non non non non
recommencez pas le cinquième profite à
la 5e
oui dernière christophe un stop de série
d'accords 4e 4e dan et dit rien de fou
qu arthur bernard jean pire parce que
j'ai moins travaillé avec jean pierre
d'accord jean pierre foucault après
reste trois dit la vérité mais dining
j'hésite entre stéphane bern et arthur
entre en troisième pas différent la
mesure troisième alors
[Rires]
j'aime bien ces femmes des droits
stéphane bern et moi pour des fans berne
deuxième break vous dites la vérité
c'est pas parce qu'on voulait travailler
avec moi parce que je veux que demain on
va voir des articles benhaim l'échelon
zidane n'a jamais mis au jour deux
heures on c'est vrai c'est vrai enfin
voilà c'est pas pareil c'est vrai voilà
vraiment rabat c'est bon alors voilà